the president has been a fully
vaccinated he had two booster shots uh
he was doing everything by precaution
wearing his mask morrow and the most uh
had been wearing their masks of course
prior to this but it was an issue i
raised with dr anthony fauci about why
this keeps happening people who get
cases sometimes repeat cases
in a world where we're told we're over
this thing take a look
everyone knows someone who's gotten this
again and sometimes again after that and
uh they're beginning to wonder
about the regimen for treating it uh you
know
whether you get two vaccination shots
whether you get a booster another
booster
they just don't know what do you tell
them there's no doubt that the vaccines
themselves particularly
vaccine plus a booster at the
appropriate time when you become
eligible for a booster for more than one
booster if you're over 50 years old you
get eligibility for two boosters
one of the things that's clear from the
data
that even though vaccines because of the
high degree of transmissibility of this
virus
don't protect overly well as it were
against infection
they protect quite well
against severe disease leading to
hospitalization
and death and
all right so the gist of what dr vaughty
was saying it could be a lot worse for
the maybe for the president himself adam
brett gerard joins us of course you
remember the good admiral the former
department of health human services
assistant secretary for health and much
much more uh when all of this exploded
during the
trump administration he was one of the
key point men in that admiral very good
to have you thank you
good to be here
let me ask you a little bit about what
dr faucia touched on that we've since
seen proven out again and again people
who've been fully vaccinated some even
getting both their booster shots uh and
still come down with this with the
argument i guess being it could have
been worse could it have been worse
well yes i agree with dr fauci tony and
i are on the same page here is that with
the new variants the vaccines
unfortunately provide very little
protection against getting infected with
covid but they still do provide
substantial protection against severe
disease like needing to be put in the
hospital or death so what you see with
the president
just like everyone else despite his
double booster he still got covid
because of the transmissibility of the
variant we're all hopeful as the data
would suggest that because he's
vaccinated and certainly on pecslovid he
can avoid a serious illness um the full
disclosure here uh and doctor you know
this i i had uh covered have it twice
the second time it was a little dicey
and intensive care and all of that now
i'm
part of the vulnerable part of the
population with a compromised immune
system i don't want to get into all of
that but i i was a little surprised that
i did everything right followed the
letter of the medical law and still came
down with a pretty pretty bad bout of
this and a lot of americans no doubt are
seeing this and hearing this today and
saying that president united states the
most powerful man on the planet
surrounded by the best medical people
probably on the planet and he comes down
with it hell no i'm not getting
vaccinated or i'm done with this whole
thing what do you tell them
well what i tell them is um what i tell
my family and what i tell myself is that
vaccines will provide
strong protection against serious
illness hospitalization and death if you
have a normal immune system or even a
modestly abnormal immune system but it's
not a guarantee a vaccine doesn't put a
force field around you so it's very
important to have a plan and many people
don't have a plan to get treated with
paxilovid or the merck drug malnupiravir
and they really need that if you're
elderly if you have chronic diseases you
really do need that layer of protection
like the president got again nothing's a
hundred percent in medicine or in life
i guess except taxes but um paxlovit and
malnupiravir on top of vaccines provide
you the best opportunity but you know a
lot of people also confused if we're
going to treat this and i know during
your administration sir and ending to
this one there had been an argument that
maybe we we start treating this as we do
the flu you get an annual shot maybe two
shots here but but that would be it uh
but you know novavax now has a vaccine
out we'll talk to that company ceo it's
the fourth vaccine to deal with this he
says it will be something promising for
the 20 or so the population that's not
been vaccinated but but some are looking
at that and saying
uh
we we go through this again and again
and again this is worse than the flu
thing this is multiple shots multiple
boosters multiple pain in the neck what
do you tell them
well i'm not saying we're going to be
there but remember we need flu shots
every year because flu is very variable
and we still lose 20 30 50 60 000
americans uh from flu every year so i i
don't want to make too much announcement
admiral i think this seems more than
because it wouldn't be just one shot
right i mean some of these guys are
saying every three months six months you
know what what are there any rules on
this i know it's constantly changing
well
well look the data don't show and and i
don't think we're going to be there that
we're going to need uh doses every three
six nine months i just don't think
that's right uh we have to understand
that the vaccines won't be perfect
protection i am very hopeful though with
an omicron specific vaccine remember
even though we've had variants this is
still the main omicron strain and when
we do get an omicron vaccine
it would hopefully provide us much
better protection novovac's very
positive about novovax i think that's a
great new
uh weapon into the game that will soon
be available and and it's a different
type of vaccine and we'll have to see
how that coverage wears out or or not or
is more durable uh under certain uh i'd
just be curious when now they're looking
into exactly uh who met the president
when where they shook hands with him how
close they got all part of the contract
racing thing he's been all over the
world as you know admiral uh
you know met with leaders you know in
saudi arabia and israel
some of the palestinian authority etc uh
to say nothing of campaign stops
including one
just yesterday
who is most vulnerable in that group and
does it in fact go back a week ago
before he was officially you know
diagnosed with this today
so we we don't know when time zero was
but one thing we can be sure of and and
they said it this morning that he was
diagnosed on an antigen test and
particularly with the omicron variants
and the current variants of omicron
ba-4ba 5 he could have been positive and
infectious for several days before he
became positive on that test so you know
going back a week is a really long time
but certainly in the two or three days
before he became positive by an antigen
test he could have been transmitting the
virus to other people so everyone who'd
been close to him are at risk but you
know i think we all have to assume we're
at some degree of risk and need to have
our uh
our guard up because it is uh out there
uh very prominently throughout the
country with these variants yeah and you
never know to your point adam gerard
thank you very much and for your service
to this country sir much appreciated
admiral gerard on all of that i went on
brian kilmeade i want you to do me a
favor i want you to click to subscribe
to the fox news youtube page this is the
only way that i know for sure that
you're not going to miss any great
commentary any great news bites any
great interviews coming your way on fox
you can get it all here on youtube so
subscribe right now